[SPEAKER_01]: That opium stick.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was... black.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kind of thick.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tainted with?
[SPEAKER_01]: Mmm, I don't think that.
[SPEAKER_01]: You awaken.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't know at what time.
[SPEAKER_01]: You awaken and actually your dreams have been very, very vivid.
[SPEAKER_01]: You remember a time
[SPEAKER_01]: You remember a time in this room when you were a child.
[SPEAKER_01]: The memory came back to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: But obviously this incense that you've been using is much stronger than the ones you're used to.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you get out of bed and wonder what time it is, putting your hands on your eyes, kind of wiping them off.
[SPEAKER_01]: You feel scratching and itching in your skin and you scratch on it, but you soon realize that it's not really your skin that's itching.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's your mind that's itching.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's something that you remember as a child.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a nervous response.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, it's a realization.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it's like, you ask the question, do I have any kind of memory as a child?
[SPEAKER_01]: One of them comes rushing back.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's your friends.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your little friends.
[SPEAKER_01]: The little gnome guys?
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where am I?
[SPEAKER_00]: Am I in like a magical forest or...
[SPEAKER_01]: No, you're in a room.
[SPEAKER_00]: A room filled with...
[SPEAKER_00]: In my dream, in my dream, I mean.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm saying that.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're in a room filled with... Well, wondrous things.
[SPEAKER_01]: And your mother is close.
[SPEAKER_01]: But through a door, there's just so many interesting things.
[SPEAKER_01]: Bottles.
[SPEAKER_01]: Devices.
[SPEAKER_01]: Potions.
[SPEAKER_01]: It draws you to them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anyway, you sit up in bed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do an int check.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's this, plus three?
[SPEAKER_00]: Wow, that was a horrible roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: What'd you roll?
[SPEAKER_00]: A four.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think it would stop my bag because of it, but...
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's something missing.
[SPEAKER_00]: The opium smoke.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was going to say that opium really hit me hard.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's heavy in this room.
[SPEAKER_00]: I need to cut those sticks in half.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to get out to my balcony.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you... Fresh air.
[SPEAKER_00]: I am off my hinges right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you rush the balcony and...
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, come out here and look down.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you look down to the royal docks and there are ships down there.
[SPEAKER_01]: These are where merchants, select merchants come and take the palace supplies and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: You see that they're down there unloading and so on.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then, lower down on the cliff, you see lights.
[SPEAKER_01]: In the residence that's lower down than you, and you know that that residence actually belongs to Lord Jamis, one of Prince Jeon's most trusted men.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, Lord Jamis is the admiral of the Monmurgian fleet at this time.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what you see.
[SPEAKER_01]: You breathe in the sea air, and your head clears.
[SPEAKER_01]: But the dream doesn't.
[SPEAKER_01]: You remember living in this room, actually, as a child.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you remember living in this room before the accident.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you also remember that there was something else.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's spaces missing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like, the room's like cut in half, or?
[SPEAKER_01]: You thought there was more to it than this.
[SPEAKER_01]: You remember sleeping here as a child, you remember eating here as a child, you remember being on the balcony again.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you remember other areas.
[SPEAKER_01]: In particular, you remember that magical room where you and your mother would go and
[SPEAKER_01]: You have a very vivid memory.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's where you played with your friends.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let me check out the closet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there like... Can I roll to see if there's something...
[SPEAKER_01]: So you walk over to the closet and you start...
[SPEAKER_01]: There are like clothes hanging in the closet still.
[SPEAKER_01]: Clothes that are like old from your childhood when your mother was there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: You have your stuff in front, but there's a lot of stuff in the back that is there also.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to take that stuff out?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you do stuff, start pulling whatever out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: You get to the back of the closet.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you do?
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I roll to do an investigation check to see if there's anything?
[SPEAKER_00]: Hidden door, boarded up wall, something.
[SPEAKER_00]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll your investigation.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, let's hope the opium wore off.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, no it didn't.
[SPEAKER_00]: Five.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's a nine.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's no good.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's a five?
[SPEAKER_00]: This wall has been plastered up.
[SPEAKER_00]: And in fact it's not, it's not stone.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's some kind of...
[SPEAKER_01]: Veneer that's been placed over this.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's a veneer?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like, you know how you have a floor and you put like a thin layer of wood over the top of it?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like concrete but you put a thin layer of veneer of wood over the top of it to basically hide the fact that it's...
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know what's on the other side of it, but...
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I break through?
[SPEAKER_00]: How do you want to do that?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to take your dagger and pry it?
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I use my intelligence to figure out how to pry a nail loose or something?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, there is definitely a place to peel from the side because this is rock and stone.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is like a weird plaster.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, okay, then I'll do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you take your dagger and kind of start working on that side, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: It peeled back and actually...
[SPEAKER_01]: Very quickly, you're ripping the stuff off the thing and you reveal, behind it, a stone door.
[SPEAKER_00]: A stone what?
[SPEAKER_01]: A stone door.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like... Hmm.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And this is basically you having to chip plaster off.
[SPEAKER_01]: Somebody just, it was like,
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, on this side of the door, just took like plaster and put it all up and down like clay and made it smooth to be a wall.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then put paper on it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Some kind of painting paint on it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, can I open the door?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, there's a key.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now the question is, you're standing here in your robe doing this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to suit up?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I probably do, realistically.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you decide to put on your set of leather.
[SPEAKER_01]: You put on your mask, okay, gloves, everything like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you try to open the door?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: It is locked.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pickpocketing skills, would I have?
[SPEAKER_00]: You have Thief's Tools.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was going to say, I have Thief's Tools.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I know how to...
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, I definitely know how to use them, but I can imagine first time for everything, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Intellectually, you know how to use them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, this door seems to be very... Technical.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not really, actually.
[SPEAKER_01]: It looks to be very simple.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you've read several manuscripts on how to be able to go and open these things.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: This actually is an opportunity for you to...
[SPEAKER_01]: Learn.
[SPEAKER_01]: Try out what you think you've learned.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Should I roll that d20?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, and so your skill with Thief's Tools should be right down there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Plus six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where would that come from?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, Thieves' Tools plus six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's twelve plus, uh, that's gonna be eighteen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eighteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, within a minute, you've taken your Thieves' Tools and unlocked the door.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Simple, simple tumble lock, probably three tumblers.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And, um...
[SPEAKER_01]: It opens inward.
[SPEAKER_01]: Revealing a narrow, long corridor.
[SPEAKER_01]: Off into the darkness.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very dark.
[SPEAKER_01]: And when I say narrow, it's about three feet wide.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I grab, like, a light source of some sort and head down?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you have a candle?
[SPEAKER_01]: If you'd rather, you could take a torch.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't have a lantern, though.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is a candle enough?
[SPEAKER_00]: Priming.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I have a torch on hand?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah, you have a torch on hand.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you light a torch and begin walking down this corridor.
[SPEAKER_01]: This thing reaches, counting your steps, probably around 50, 60 feet, okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: And it slightly is going down.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so the angle is not severe.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it like steps down or is it...?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not steps down.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's basically just a very, very slow decline towards where you're going.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, after 60 feet, it opens up and there are steps that descend.
[SPEAKER_01]: Keep going.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, with your torch in front of you, you descend probably another 20 feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: The stairs are 15, this is a steep descent, and then this opens up into a larger corridor.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, the corridor looks unused, dark, and there are cobwebs.
[SPEAKER_01]: In the corners.
[SPEAKER_01]: It looks as if nobody has been in here for years.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nothing eye-catching?
[SPEAKER_01]: Not really.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's very, very empty.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like I said, there's dust, there's cobwebs.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's about it.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess I keep moving.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I hear anything?
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, no, but up ahead you do see, you see light, loom light.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, you start to realize you've been here before.
[SPEAKER_01]: You remember this.
[SPEAKER_01]: You get flashbacks to when you were younger.
[SPEAKER_01]: You've walked this before.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anyway,
[SPEAKER_01]: You keep going, correct?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: Soon you come to a... Open, this is like a archway.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And on the other side of it there's an archway as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: This looks like a guardrail.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the moonlight that you see is coming through arrow slits.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: This continues.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there anything on the right hand side of the wall?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, this looks to be abandoned as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Doesn't seem like there's much here.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are some, I would say, bird droppings?
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, along the window seal, as if birds had been here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: But, um, and there are some, like, old birds nests in this area, but it doesn't seem like...
[SPEAKER_01]: Rats.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe rats.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't see evidence of rats, but it looks like this has been a, this is a part of the castle that has been definitely, um, neglected and not used for a very long time.
[SPEAKER_01]: How long do I think?
[SPEAKER_00]: Years.
[SPEAKER_01]: Decade.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe 15 years.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's keep going.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: The pool goes another 20 feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then you come to a spiral staircase that goes down into the darkness.
[SPEAKER_01]: Down?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, it spirals down.
[SPEAKER_00]: Does it go up or just down?
[SPEAKER_01]: Just down.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I see anything looking over the rail down?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or is it just empty darkness?
[SPEAKER_01]: You see... Actually, you cannot see the floor.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, I guess I head down.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, you descend what you think to be, I would say, another 50 feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, from here... That's... That's 20 feet down.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's probably 10 feet down.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's another... That's 20 feet down.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's 30 feet down.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's 80 feet down from below where your room is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And... You come into a... Let me draw that.
[SPEAKER_01]: There we go.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is the top, this is the bottom.
[SPEAKER_01]: You come into an area that looks like this.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's a door here.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's a door here.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then the passage continues that way.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, the passage continues and then you see it open up into a larger area that way.
[SPEAKER_01]: So where's the top of the stairs?
[SPEAKER_01]: So this is where you come from.
[SPEAKER_01]: The top of the stairs is up here, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: You spiral down.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is the bottom level of the stairs.
[SPEAKER_01]: And, sorry my drawing's horrible, but there's a door here, a door there, and this corridor continues and opens up into another area.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um, alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, if I'm like, what, right here probably?
[SPEAKER_01]: Mhm.
[SPEAKER_00]: Then I guess I'll check the first door to my left.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I see anything down the hallway?
[SPEAKER_00]: Farther, or...?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, it's dark.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the torch, your torchlight allows you to see pretty much out to here well, and then out to here just in what's known as half-light.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which means that...
[SPEAKER_01]: Somebody could be concealed if they were good in that light.
[SPEAKER_01]: If they wanted to be.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, I'll check the first door on my left.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so you go up to the first door and what do you check?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it open or unlocked?
[SPEAKER_00]: It is unlocked.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there usage of this door or hallway?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or is it just like the other rooms?
[SPEAKER_01]: It looks pretty... pretty abandoned.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um, I guess I'll open it and see what's in it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you open the door and peer in with your torch, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And what you see in there is... a room.
[SPEAKER_01]: And right here is a bookcase.
[SPEAKER_01]: You see a chair here.
[SPEAKER_01]: But that's about it in the darkness.
[SPEAKER_01]: You remember sitting in that chair as a child, and actually your mother reading to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nice, nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, can I keep going farther down this room?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, there's darkness over here, but if you want to enter the room, you can definitely do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I would like to.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you walk into this room.
[SPEAKER_01]: Another bookcase.
[SPEAKER_01]: Another chair right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the chairs are actually very obviously opulent, well made.
[SPEAKER_01]: But rotted and disused.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the books on the shelves look as if they have not been touched in years.
[SPEAKER_00]: That door, can I check out that door?
[SPEAKER_00]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is it unlocked or open?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's unlocked.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's actually pale light coming from arrow slits there and there.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you open the room, you open the door, and you get this overwhelming sense of dread.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's a bed here.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's a table here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Instantly, you recognize this place.
[SPEAKER_01]: You've slept here before as a child.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your mother would bring you here often.
[SPEAKER_00]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_00]: So there's a bed and a what?
[SPEAKER_01]: There's a table here with like some items on it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically a goblet, a book.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can check all that stuff out later.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's laying there.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you remember sleeping on that bed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Remember your mother putting you in that bed.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it's rotted.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like tattered at this point.
[SPEAKER_01]: Weird.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I continue going into the room.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll a saving throw.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a wisdom-based saving throw.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, wisdom's plus two.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's gonna be thirteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eleven, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You cautiously enter the room.
[SPEAKER_01]: However...
[SPEAKER_01]: You're basically shaking in fear.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're starting to remember what happened.
[SPEAKER_01]: You walk into the room.
[SPEAKER_01]: There is a door here.
[SPEAKER_01]: It is open.
[SPEAKER_01]: Already?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, it's gone.
[SPEAKER_01]: The door's gone.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: Destroyed.
[SPEAKER_01]: And there are scorch marks on the ground right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Explosion.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And there's a chest sitting right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: In your mind's eye, you basically remember, as a child, getting out of the bed, your mother
[SPEAKER_01]: Sleeping next to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your interest in what was in this room was what led you to it.
[SPEAKER_01]: There were so many beautiful things in there that you just had to go and see what it was.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I don't want to enter the room, but can I get up to the doorway?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you walk up to here?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, about there.
[SPEAKER_01]: The doorway?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, you see this.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not doing this justice, but I'll do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the scorch marks continue.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's what looks like the remnants of a broken and burnt out table, and then a cistern right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: On the floor there are burnt metal and glass containers, beakers, tubes, things like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: But in your mind you know that when you were a child, maybe six, you see yourself coming into this room and reaching for one of the containers on the table.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your clumsy childish hands knocked it over.
[SPEAKER_01]: Glass broke.
[SPEAKER_01]: Strange fluids conjoined together.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the room exploded in flames.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that's the last that you'll remember.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is the place the accident happened.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I grabbed a flask of some sort and... and like...
[SPEAKER_01]: There was some kind of strange material, you guess, in this.
[SPEAKER_01]: I enter the room.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so you walk into the room with your torch.
[SPEAKER_01]: It continues this way.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are some barrels in the corner there.
[SPEAKER_01]: This door is intact.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where do the scorching marks stop?
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically, this is the area.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's go check out that door.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you walk over to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Glass crunching under your feet as you walk over the broken beakers.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's a strange smell here, even now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kind of metallic.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sort of like ozone as you walk over them.
[SPEAKER_01]: The barrels here are not large, about like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: And they have each red X's painted, three red X's painted on each one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_00]: Does, like, the barrels catch my eye, or is that, like, something...?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, your eye's being caught by all of these strange devices.
[SPEAKER_00]: Am I, like, wanting to open it and see what's in it, or is it just not standing out to me?
[SPEAKER_00]: Doing a check.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nat 20.
[SPEAKER_01]: You remember your mother telling you not to go near it.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, she literally told you...
[SPEAKER_01]: That's dangerous stuff, Paul.
[SPEAKER_01]: Breathing in even a minute amount of that will kill you.
[SPEAKER_01]: You vividly remember her warning you off from this.
[SPEAKER_01]: You kinda wonder why she brought you down here in the first place.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I open it?
[SPEAKER_01]: What's that?
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I open it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Could you open this?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, there's like a lid to it or is it like...
[SPEAKER_01]: There's definitely a lid to it.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, there is a, um, kind of a metal lever that will like seal the top.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, I open it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you take your thing and pop it back?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: It opens.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you're holding your torch?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'm going to set that to the...
[SPEAKER_01]: Sorry, I should have...
[SPEAKER_00]: There are scones in the wall if you want to... Yeah, let's... Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Put that good safe.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you stick your...
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know if it's gunpowder or...
[SPEAKER_00]: It's all... You know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Blow to the wall, and that's my session.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll see myself out.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you stick the torch in a scone.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: 10 feet away.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a good spot for it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, yeah, I open it up and...
[SPEAKER_00]: So you take the top off?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, this thing is not big, it's small.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you take off the top and inside you see this grayish, whitish powder.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I recognize it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Um...
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll a...
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a history check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll a history check.
[SPEAKER_00]: I do not have history, I believe.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I do not.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just in tone.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that's gonna be a six, added up.
[SPEAKER_01]: You do not recognize it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: But...
[SPEAKER_01]: There is a very strange smell associated with it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna take like a little bag or something.
[SPEAKER_00]: Take a little and just sip it up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so...
[SPEAKER_01]: And it's a powder, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a powder.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you're going to take a little container, and what do you want to use to scoop it up with?
[SPEAKER_01]: You want your finger?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, you wear gloves.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, I'll just dip the bag or whatever I'm using to scoop it up in there.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, if you wanted to, you could take a piece of glass off the ground and do it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, yeah, I guess I could do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, sure, I'll take a piece of glass.
[SPEAKER_00]: Does the X's on the barrel stand out to me?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a symbol of...
[SPEAKER_01]: It's familiar to you in some strange way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, you would probably have to do some research, but it's like not... You feel like you...
[SPEAKER_01]: I need to hit the books.
[SPEAKER_01]: You need to understand about this.
[SPEAKER_01]: You've seen an image of this stuff, but it's been a long time.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I get the stuff and... Get a little sample of the stuff, put it in your leather bag.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna close it back up.
[SPEAKER_00]: You put the top on, close it back up.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then I'm gonna grab my torch.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then I'm gonna, you know, go down and check that door out.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you go down to this door, open it up, and you see the last room.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you come in here.
[SPEAKER_01]: And this room is empty, except for the fact that it's got this large, strange oven right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nothing else.
[SPEAKER_01]: Otherwise, it's empty.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hang on a second.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You hear something in the oven.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_00]: A scuttling.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I should get my blade out and stand at the ready.
[SPEAKER_00]: What, which blade?
[SPEAKER_00]: The dagger or the short sword?
[SPEAKER_00]: The dagger.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you pull out your dagger.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you do?
[SPEAKER_01]: I stand at the ready.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you got an action saved.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: You hear something in there sniffing the air.
[SPEAKER_01]: As if it's just awakened.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does it sound big?
[SPEAKER_00]: Like... How big?
[SPEAKER_00]: Not huge.
[SPEAKER_00]: Bigger than a cat.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: That was an immediate yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Bigger than a dog.
[SPEAKER_01]: I wouldn't...
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know about that.
[SPEAKER_01]: You've got an action ready.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're standing there with your action ready.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, all of a sudden, this creature runs out of the oven as if coming down the stairs.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's bigger than a cat.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's about that big.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Runs down the stairs and leaps at you.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have an action ready.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, you can take your action where you can dodge, which means that the attack on you will be at disadvantage.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can do something where you attack it before it gets to you, if you want to do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I see it?
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, I have my torch, so.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, no, you see it coming at you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, is it like an oversized rat?
[SPEAKER_00]: It is an oversized rat.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, that's what I thought.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, if it's lunging at me, I'll just attack it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just stick the torch in its face and...
[SPEAKER_00]: So do you want to attack, you want to hit it with the torch?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I'll just, well, if I have my torch in my left hand, and my dagger in my right, and I'm leading with my torch, I guess what I'm saying is, it's gonna jump right at into my torch.
[SPEAKER_01]: So there is something called dual weapon fighting which means that if you want to you can use your offhand weapon as an attack as a bonus action.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if you want to attack with your torch and then attack with your bonus action you can do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: However when you do that with your dagger on your offhand you do not get your dexterity pluses that you normally would for damage I believe.
[SPEAKER_01]: You might get them to hit.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a great question, actually.
[SPEAKER_00]: So let me look at dual weapon fighting.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're probably right on the two hit, but I can't see the damage part.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I know that there's not an advantage to the damage when you're doing offhand attacks.
[SPEAKER_01]: So let me look at this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Dual weapon fighting.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or is that dueling?
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, I think the easiest way to look at this is look at fighting style, dueling, defensive grip, two weapon fighting.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: When you engage in two-weapon fighting, you can add your ability modifier to the damage of the second attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: So normally you don't get that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you're gonna smash it with the torch.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's a bonus action, and then hit him with my dagger.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let me check this out.
[SPEAKER_01]: When you take an attack action and attack with a light weapon when you're holding one hand, you can use a bonus action to attack with a different light melee weapon that you're holding in the other hand.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't add your ability modifier to the damage of the bonus attack unless that modifier is negative.
[SPEAKER_01]: If either weapon has thrown property, you can throw the weapon instead of making a melee attack with it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So which hand do you want to be your attack action?
[SPEAKER_01]: Your dagger or the torch?
[SPEAKER_01]: I want my dagger to be the main action.
[SPEAKER_01]: Main action?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh... dice?
[SPEAKER_01]: You attack the creature with your knife?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, what's a dagger?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's gonna be 11 plus... 6, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, no, dexterity's 4.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, proficiency bonus, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that is a hit, and the damage is 1 die for plus 4, because you're using this to do your damage bonus.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that's the die, the tetrahedron.
[SPEAKER_01]: The what?
[SPEAKER_00]: Tetrahedron.
[SPEAKER_00]: The four-sided die.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've never been called that in my entire life.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that's a three plus... Four you said?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, three plus four because... Nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: The creature leaps at you.
[SPEAKER_01]: And with your left-handed dagger, you slash at it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oops, sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: And catch it in the throat.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cutting its throat and throwing it to the side.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to keep your bonus action?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: This thing dies.
[SPEAKER_01]: It is like squealing on the floor there, writhing in pain as blood comes out of its throat.
[SPEAKER_01]: Another comes to attack you.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to use your bonus action?
[SPEAKER_01]: I do.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: The rat leaps at you and you try to club it with your right hand.
[SPEAKER_01]: You get a, you have a plus, you're not proficient with these things, so you have a plus four with this club, with the torch.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: To hit?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, I just went at 20.
[SPEAKER_00]: This creature jumps at you, but before it can leave.
[SPEAKER_01]: Mouth open, just right on it.
[SPEAKER_01]: You put your torch on it, burning it for, one died four for the clubbing damage, and then another died four for the burning damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: So three plus four.
[SPEAKER_01]: It squeals, lights on fire, and writhes to death underneath the torch that you hold on it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically you hold it there until it quits moving.
[SPEAKER_01]: No others come out of the chimney.
[SPEAKER_00]: Paul's a killer.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: Very nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's no more in the oven.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just chillin'.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to go there and like check it out?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you go into there with the torch and look inside and there's like a nest full of...
[SPEAKER_01]: Baby rats.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, not actually baby rats, but like feces and cotton and whatever else they found.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've seen a rat nest.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, the oven does go straight up and it looks like there's a chimney that
[SPEAKER_01]: This is obviously the way they got in.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it basically goes up into, you don't know where, obviously the outside.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can see the moon out there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Strange oven though.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is like a...
[SPEAKER_01]: Not a cooking oven.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not a cooking oven, even though you could probably cook something in it, but there are like these... Potion-making ovens?
[SPEAKER_01]: Wrecks, very possibly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is like where you would boil stuff, and there are like holders, and you see more than one or two glass beakers.
[SPEAKER_00]: Could I make an intelligence roll?
[SPEAKER_00]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's gonna be a 16.
[SPEAKER_00]: These look like alchemical devices.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, alright, my mom's a witch.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, um... Next door, I guess.
[SPEAKER_00]: You wanna go to this one?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I got, you know... Alright, so you go over to that door... and open it, and you find yourself... back in the hallway, basically.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, this is like this, actually.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can you find yourself here?
[SPEAKER_01]: And there is a, it's not that wide, it's like that wide, corridor reaching forward like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Huh.
[SPEAKER_00]: I guess it continued going down.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which way does this go?
[SPEAKER_00]: Does it keep going this way or is it going back?
[SPEAKER_01]: So here's the stair here, here's the stair here.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is faced correctly.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if we took this and put it underneath there, it'd be going that way too.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is to, I would say, that is east, that is south.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I continue going down the hallway.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would say about 50 feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then right here there's a corner that turns this way.
[SPEAKER_01]: This continues to here and then starts going that direction.
[SPEAKER_00]: Weird.
[SPEAKER_01]: You see moonlight over here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, um... Let me check the left first.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you come over this way?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's still like a window.
[SPEAKER_01]: Stairs up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not too high, maybe like four feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just a couple of stairs up.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then what appears to be kind of a lookout post or a guard room.
[SPEAKER_01]: Weird.
[SPEAKER_01]: Arrow slits, looking out the same direction as your room does.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lower down, looking towards the ocean, but the royal docks are over this way.
[SPEAKER_01]: So this is another fortification.
[SPEAKER_01]: If there ever was an attack, maybe guards would be here with arrows.
[SPEAKER_01]: But again, this area looks like it's been abandoned or not used in a long, long time.
[SPEAKER_01]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, where do I stand?
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you mean, where do you stand?
[SPEAKER_00]: You're right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm right there?
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nothing significant in that room?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's bare.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll go back the other way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: So.
[SPEAKER_01]: Here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Stairs.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very much like those.
[SPEAKER_01]: Going down maybe four feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: This continues.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then there is a door right here.
[SPEAKER_00]: I hate to say it, Adrian, but I think that hike really took a lot out of me and I had to eat three pieces of chicken.
[SPEAKER_00]: I left you one.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You demolished the chicken we had.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_00]: I love some good chicken.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's a door.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's check the door out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a stone door.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very similar to the one that you had opened here, actually.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Locked.
[SPEAKER_01]: You try the handle?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: It is locked.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which?
[SPEAKER_01]: Pick it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you try to pick it?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: Aw, man.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eight plus six?
[SPEAKER_00]: That's gonna be fourteen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fourteen, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, the other door was simple to pick.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you don't really see anything special necessarily about this door.
[SPEAKER_01]: But what's strange is every time you put your lock in there, your pick in there, and start jiggling it, strangely enough...
[SPEAKER_01]: It's as if something is on the other side pushing your pick out of the door.
[SPEAKER_01]: You try for like three minutes.
[SPEAKER_01]: This other side was easy for you.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, there's something, it feels like there's something on the other side working against you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll a 20-sided die.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ten.
[SPEAKER_00]: Magic?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, there's something... Magic?
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, there's...
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm thinking a mouse is just in there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Either there's somebody on the other side pushing on your pick whenever you put it in, or there's something else happening.
[SPEAKER_01]: You even look through the hole, and there is not... another eyeball up there with a key or anything!
[SPEAKER_01]: He's all, why is this key not... Do you want to keep trying?
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I knock on the door and see if someone responds?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to try that?
[SPEAKER_00]: I do.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you knock on the door.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: How long do you want to do that?
[SPEAKER_00]: I just wanted to do it once.
[SPEAKER_00]: No response.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, alright, yeah, that's cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe not my dagger would work.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I don't know if my sword's too thick, but could I fit something in there to try and poke it to see if anything happens?
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you mean, poke what?
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: You said that there's something in there that's pushing it back, so can I... Well, I mean, you looked in there, there's nothing that you could see.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, okay, then...
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, it's as if some invisible force, like a lodestone or whatever, was magnetizing your thing and pushing the thing backwards.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nge, can I make an intelligence roll to see what I should do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's gonna be 14 again.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can keep trying to pick the lock, or... Or?
[SPEAKER_01]: Give up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean it doesn't it doesn't it doesn't seem like uh I mean maybe there's a key oh yeah possibly it's not like hung up on the wall right there next to the door is it no you don't see there there's nothing around here all right cool however however you do see a light off in the distance
[SPEAKER_01]: So, based on the distance that you traveled,
[SPEAKER_01]: And the elevation that you've gone down...
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a main hallway that's...
[SPEAKER_00]: This is in Lord Jamis' residence.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now...
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't know if you want to just go in there unannounced.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I think that you probably could go in there, and Jamis wouldn't have you killed, obviously.
[SPEAKER_01]: If he caught you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: But, it would be impolite.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: No doubt about that.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, I mean, the whole question is...
[SPEAKER_01]: The thought crosses your mind.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your mother had basically a kind of a secret laboratory that she took you to when she was a child, when you were a child that had a direct connection to Laura Jamis' residence.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Weird.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know what to do.
[SPEAKER_00]: I could leave the door, I could head back, maybe check some stuff out.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or I could open the door.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you said this is probably his main room, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_00]: The door connects to, like... Oh, this door?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, Ward Jameson's... His residence.
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviously not his manor.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, this is probably as remote a part of where he lives as your room is to where Prince Jeon lives.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let me try and pick that lock again.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh no, I'm not gonna do that at all.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you actually stick the lock in and forcibly it ejects.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: As if some unseen force pushed it out.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, that's cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: I won't mess with that no more.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, I know what I'm not wanting.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll just take my lock and stroll back this way and check some items out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you take your torch and walk back this direction.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: You said that there was a chest in there?
[SPEAKER_00]: Right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's look at that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you walk back into this room.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to go this way or...?
[SPEAKER_01]: Doesn't matter.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, do you want to walk through broken glass and dead rat blood?
[SPEAKER_01]: Not really.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it does kind of matter.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you walk back through the library, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you walk back into the room where...
[SPEAKER_01]: The bed is.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the chest is probably about this big.
[SPEAKER_01]: Standing right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sitting right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Every time I look at a chest, I always run across my mind that's a mimic.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the best way to tell if it's a mimic is to just sit there and stare at it, because mimics have to breathe.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you can watch it open its mouth, which I'm gonna do.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm assuming my character would know that as I've spent 20 years of my life looking at books.
[SPEAKER_00]: Reading horror stories about adventurers who come across and lost their hands with mimics.
[SPEAKER_00]: One of my players did that.
[SPEAKER_00]: They were in a dungeon and there was a chest and he's like a kid and he's like, oh I run for the chest and I'm like, I got him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Opens the chest and he lost his hand.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or he lost part of it, but yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is it a mimic though?
[SPEAKER_01]: So you sit there and watch it?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do a perception.
[SPEAKER_00]: A perception?
[SPEAKER_00]: Perception check.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, is that charisma?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, that's wisdom.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wisdom.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, then that's 14.
[SPEAKER_00]: 14?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: It, you know, doesn't...
[SPEAKER_01]: Look like it's breathing.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't like that hesitation.
[SPEAKER_01]: The opium is kind of worn off.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know what I mean?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll give you the opium excuse.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: But the chest does not look like it's breathing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to open it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't think you're that cruel and would throw a mimic to me at first level.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, you take the lid and you want to... How do you want to open it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to take your dagger and open it?
[SPEAKER_01]: There's no lock on it.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I'll just open it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So...
[SPEAKER_01]: Do the thing and you open it and look in there.
[SPEAKER_01]: And there are books there, but what really catches your eye is there are these three little clay figurines about that big
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's like one here, one here, one here, of various sizes.
[SPEAKER_01]: The books are kind of in the middle, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: There's another little box in there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: And you recognize the little figures.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're like little teeny creatures.
[SPEAKER_01]: These are your friends.
[SPEAKER_01]: These were the things that you would play with as a kid.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, your mother would take them out of the box and... You remember this.
[SPEAKER_01]: These were your little buddies.
[SPEAKER_01]: They were like little...
[SPEAKER_01]: Kind of gargoyles, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Little goblinoids with teeny little wings and basically just sitting there.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, the box right here you remember very well because your mother would... that was your mom's.
[SPEAKER_01]: She would take that out
[SPEAKER_01]: And actually sit in this room and read letters and cry for hours.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I take that little box.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you reach down and take the little box.
[SPEAKER_01]: This figurine comes to life and bites your hand.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or tries to bite your hand.
[SPEAKER_01]: He sucks.
[SPEAKER_01]: He does suck.
[SPEAKER_01]: He grabs onto your hand and starts biting.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, your leather glove protects you from his teeny teeth.
[SPEAKER_01]: Rollin' ish.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now he's got sharp teeth, but luckily his bite does not enter your skin.
[SPEAKER_01]: It like bites through your glove though.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, it's gonna be a plus four.
[SPEAKER_01]: The other two do not move.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fourteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: You get a fourteen?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, he's... Five, seven.
[SPEAKER_01]: You get the initiative.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to grab him and pop him.
[SPEAKER_01]: You want to just try and grab him with your one hand?
[SPEAKER_01]: The hand that he's... You can do what's called grapple, which is you grab onto him so he can't move.
[SPEAKER_00]: I guess, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'll do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, I have a hard...
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, if he's latched onto my hand, I have a hard time seeing him dodge...
[SPEAKER_00]: This is the weirdest thing ever.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've never had a little...
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know what it is, but I've never had an enemy inside a chest that's two inches tall that's...
[SPEAKER_00]: He's a little taller than that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, four inches.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's maybe about... Oh, that's way bigger.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, about that big.
[SPEAKER_01]: But he is kind of like a little lizard with wings kind of thing.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is random.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you try to grab him with your other hand?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is this a bonus action, technically?
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, it's not.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a... this is your attack action.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I just grab him and squeeze him to death?
[SPEAKER_00]: Is he stone?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or clay, you said?
[SPEAKER_00]: He's made out of clay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll your attack.
[SPEAKER_00]: Would I use acrobatics?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, this is an unarmed grapple attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Would he use dex then?
[SPEAKER_01]: I think that this might be grappling.
[SPEAKER_01]: When you want to grab a creature or wrestle with it, you can use the attack action to make a special melee attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you are able to make multiple attacks with the attack action, the attack replaces one of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: The target of your grapple must be no more than one size larger than you, which he is not.
[SPEAKER_01]: Using at least one freehand, you try to seize the target by making a grapple attack
[SPEAKER_01]: Check on an attack roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: A strength athletics check contested by the target's strength athletics check or dexterity acrobatics check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you have to make an athletics check compared to his dexterity.
[SPEAKER_01]: So your athletics...
[SPEAKER_01]: It's just plus two with my strength.
[SPEAKER_01]: ...is plus two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So go for it.
[SPEAKER_01]: And if he rolls higher, he avoids 17, 18, 19, so...
[SPEAKER_01]: 19, 13, 14, 15.
[SPEAKER_01]: You grab him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, in your hand.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it's squirming, struggling, okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: It tries to bite you again.
[SPEAKER_01]: 16, 17, 18.
[SPEAKER_01]: This time, it's fangs.
[SPEAKER_01]: Get into your hand, and you feel the sting of its bite.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now...
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll a...
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll a... Constitution saving throw.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, you roll an ish every time?
[SPEAKER_00]: I do it every time.
[SPEAKER_01]: That makes the combat go really weird.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's different.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, I sucked that round.
[SPEAKER_01]: 3, 10.
[SPEAKER_00]: That was a 5, by the way, which is a 9.
[SPEAKER_01]: A 9.
[SPEAKER_00]: He gets a 10, 12.
[SPEAKER_01]: He bites you again.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, my gosh.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: 10, 11, 12.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's your AC?
[SPEAKER_01]: 16.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Again, he's biting on your hand, trying to get his fangs into you again.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you see strange...
[SPEAKER_01]: Yellowish liquid coming out of his fangs.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is so out of BS.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to take my dagger and slit this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you take, you pull out your knife and you try to end him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, roll your attack.
[SPEAKER_00]: 8 plus dexterity with the dagger, so that's going to be... Plus 6.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, uh, then, yeah, 14.
[SPEAKER_00]: 14.
[SPEAKER_00]: That hits.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um... 1.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's just one-sided.
[SPEAKER_01]: 1 plus, um... 1 plus 4.
[SPEAKER_01]: 5.
[SPEAKER_01]: 5 put points.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you take this thing and you chop its head off.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: It is still struggling.
[SPEAKER_01]: What the...
[SPEAKER_01]: Its head rolls down onto the bottom of the chest.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it's like, ahhh!
[SPEAKER_01]: But once you cut the head off, you expose this green stone.
[SPEAKER_01]: The body is still struggling.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, it cannot attack you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let me just back up and put this thing on a...
[SPEAKER_00]: Subtitles by the Amara.org community
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you're not giving, putting your hand off it, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I'm not letting go of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you put your hand on the table like that, and then take the dagger.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we start to pry the rock out or something.
[SPEAKER_01]: And pop the stone out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll, no, no, no, I think you would just easily do it.
[SPEAKER_01]: You pop out the little green stone, and it falls on the table.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the thing quits struggling.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: Take the stone.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll put that in my pocket and save it for later.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm gonna go look back and make sure those other two statues are there.
[SPEAKER_00]: They are.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just sitting there.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're just gonna... poke one of them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like...
[SPEAKER_00]: Nothing happens.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, then I'm gonna...
[SPEAKER_01]: The, um... the head... has quit... making motions with its mouth.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I grab the body?
[SPEAKER_00]: Is this a magic manipulated item?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do an arcana roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: 18.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wow, I know my magic.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a... yeah, so...
[SPEAKER_01]: This is some kind of an artifice, an artificer's thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And actually, what you notice is on top of the stack of books, there's a book that has a title on it that says, Creating a Homunculus.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you think you've heard of homunculus before.
[SPEAKER_00]: What are they?
[SPEAKER_00]: If they're what I think they are.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, some mages basically would create clay familiars that they would use to spy on people.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Out of clay.
[SPEAKER_00]: That would be a good book.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's take that book.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so you take that book and pick it out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are two other books underneath it.
[SPEAKER_00]: That says?
[SPEAKER_00]: They're untitled.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I flip through the pages?
[SPEAKER_00]: You want to pick one up and start looking through it?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't tell me another one pops out.
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a magical tome.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a what?
[SPEAKER_00]: These are spells.
[SPEAKER_00]: Magical.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's somebody's spell book.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll just take that with me as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's probably my mom's, realistically.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'll take that one too.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: What about the other one?
[SPEAKER_00]: Same thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I'll take that one too.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you take both of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I do.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the Homunculus book.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: What about the chest?
[SPEAKER_00]: What else is in it?
[SPEAKER_00]: What's the stuff?
[SPEAKER_00]: The letters?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, there's the... Oh, I never even got the box.
[SPEAKER_00]: You haven't even got the box.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's get that box out there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you pick up the box.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is it like a box you can open?
[SPEAKER_00]: Absolutely, you can open it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool, let's open it.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are stacks of letters in it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe, I would say at least a dozen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, so I'll save that for later then.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll take that box with me.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then what's the other pile of...
[SPEAKER_00]: There is no other pile.
[SPEAKER_00]: There were three books.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, the three books, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: The box and then the three little statuettes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll take the statuettes with me.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I can try and make one of those maybe for in the future or something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So one other thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: There is another green stone in this box as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_01]: Almost identical to the one... Why didn't I see it before?
[SPEAKER_01]: You didn't open it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Remember, the little creature attacked you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_01]: I thought I said I did open it.
[SPEAKER_01]: You tried to.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the creature attacked you, as if trying to defend it.
[SPEAKER_01]: I said I grabbed the little box and opened it, though.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, and you found the letters.
[SPEAKER_01]: But also, I just...
[SPEAKER_00]: I wanted to tell you also, you saw one of the green stones.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, yeah, yeah, from that scene.
[SPEAKER_00]: I forgot.
[SPEAKER_00]: I apologize.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, then, um... Yeah, I'll take... Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Take the little statues with me, too.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I got a lot of shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: I already checked out the barrels.
[SPEAKER_00]: Everything else is burnt in that room.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's just a table, I'm pretty sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: That was a cistern where you would, like, pour stuff.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, I'm not gonna mess with that.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then there's just some bookshelves over here and here that I can look at, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, let's go look at those.
[SPEAKER_00]: Histories.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are some books you recognize.
[SPEAKER_01]: Some books were actually, you know, fairy stories, fairy tale stories, histories.
[SPEAKER_01]: Some are a little stranger that are written in like a language you recognize as Suel, which is different than what Common is, but you don't read it, you don't know it.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you can recognize it when you see it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um, is there any books that just stand out to me here?
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll your arcana.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fourteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: There is one really thick big book called The Magnum Opus that stands out to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do our Arcana check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fifteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wow, I just love... You've heard of this book!
[SPEAKER_01]: This actually was a book written by a very powerful wizard.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very, very powerful and very...
[SPEAKER_01]: Well known?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well known and popular wizard.
[SPEAKER_01]: He was actually considered to be a very enlightened wizard.
[SPEAKER_01]: He was one of the powerful transmuters that existed in Keoland a long time ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: This was back in the days when, this was way before the sea principalities even existed.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: But the Magnum Opus is said to have been his greatest work.
[SPEAKER_01]: That he disseminated to all the people.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he basically said that transmutation is magical, but that even commoners can do it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he was kind of this guy that would teach people how to do magical things with common knowledge, as it were.
[SPEAKER_01]: His name was Ujor Udias.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's well-known.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, you don't know the exact history.
[SPEAKER_01]: If he did?
[SPEAKER_01]: He would die maybe 600, 700 years ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, okay, cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: On the front of the book... ...is this symbol.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't be a...
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's not, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, that's not good.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, that's weird.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I'm just gonna put that in my pocket as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not a pocket thing, it's a, it's a hefty tome.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hold that in a, under a shoulder.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um, and I, and I checked out both these things, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, then, um,
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's boogie.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm outta here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you head back to your room.
[SPEAKER_01]: You go up the stairs.
[SPEAKER_01]: Come through here and find yourself maybe at 3 in the morning.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have no idea.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think I got up at like 1, you said.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, something like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, back in your room with all these artifacts that you have.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, that's awesome.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um, I'm going to...
[SPEAKER_00]: Put this back together.
[SPEAKER_01]: You want to close the door.
[SPEAKER_01]: To re-plaster, you have to have plaster.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not re-plaster.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can just throw it away.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, um...
[SPEAKER_00]: Put the clothes back in.
[SPEAKER_00]: Put the backs of the clothes and the boxes and all back in and stuff.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um... And once I do that, I guess I will either... Well, I can't go back to...
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not smoking more opium.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll just read some books and stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you start, you look at the books.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: The only one you can really understand, so first off the Magnum Opus is thick and it has a lot of information about what's called alchemy.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a very practical book that talks about how you can distill
[SPEAKER_01]: Plants to get their alchemical properties from them, to make things like medicines, to do things like make sure you don't get sick.
[SPEAKER_01]: It talks about things like plumbing.
[SPEAKER_01]: How to read plaster wall without plaster.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two of those books are not something you can decipher.
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviously, these are magical tomes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Different language?
[SPEAKER_01]: Magical language.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have to know magic to be able to do that and to understand it.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have to study this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool, cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's just shove these books under the bed, I guess.
[SPEAKER_01]: The third one, though, if you look at it, is called Creating a Homunculus.
[SPEAKER_01]: Translated by Grayson Jamis.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is he a big significance?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or do I not know him?
[SPEAKER_00]: You've never heard of him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You see my dad?
[SPEAKER_00]: We don't.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Did I just crack the code?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, alright, I'll read the book.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I read it at least?
[SPEAKER_00]: The Creating a Homunculus?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, I'll read that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, well send it here.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think this is a good place to stop.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I will send you the book.
[SPEAKER_01]: That would be awesome.
[SPEAKER_00]: I love the tape recording idea because that definitely makes no taping.